بحث طبي آخر
يعيق علاجًا لمساعدة الأشخاص المصابين
بفيروس كورونا على تأجيل
تجربة العلاج بالأجسام المضادة التي
يطورها إيلي ليلي على
غرار ما تناوله دونالد ترامب عندما
توقف مؤقتًا عن فيروس كورونا بسبب مخاوف محتملة
تتعلق بالسلامة تأتي بعد يوم من جونسون و.
قالت جونسون إنها أوقفت مؤقتًا التجربة السريرية المتقدمة
للقاح التجريبي الخاص بها
لأن أحد متطوعيها عانى
من مرض ولم تذكر الشركة
ماهية المرض ،
فهذه هي المرحلة الثانية من تجربة اللقاح
التي تم إيقافها مؤقتًا في الولايات المتحدة
بعد توقف astrazeneca الشهر الماضي
الجدول الزمني للقاح في خطر ،
أعتقد أنه من المحتمل أن يكون لدينا
لقاح أو لقاحات بحلول أوائل العام المقبل ،
وأعتقد أن هذه التوقفات السريرية تؤدي إلى
إبطاء الأمور إلى حد ما ، لكنني أعتقد
على المدى الطويل أننا سنرى ذلك على أنه نتوء
في الطريق
لكن عدد الولايات التي لديها زيادات
في الحالات الجديدة يستمر
في الارتفاع 33 ولاية اعتبارًا من يوم الثلاثاء في اتجاه
تصاعدي
مع متوسط البلد الذي يبلغ متوسطه حوالي 50000 حا
ة جديدة  قال
الدكتور أنتوني فاوسي ، سا يوم ، إنه قلق بشكل خاص
بشأن الارتفاعات المركزية في الولايات المتحدة
في معدلات الإيجابية
التي غالبًا ما تكون في الواقع
تنبئ بشكل كبير
بعودة الحالات التي
نعرفها تاريخيًا أنها
تؤدي إلى زيادة في حالات العلاج في المستشفيات
ومن ثم في نهاية المطاف زيادة في
الوفيات
[موسيقى  ]
في ناشفيل تينيسي ، يحقق المسؤولون في
هذا الحفل الديني يوم
الأحد ، حيث
يحتشد مئات الأشخاص معًا ،
ولا يرتدون أقنعة ،
وهو عامل آخر محتمل للغاية
، يشعر الخبراء بالقلق الآن بشأن
تجمع الرئيس ترامب المزدحم في
فلوريدا يوم
الاثنين ، المشكلة هي أنه في حين أن هناك
أشخاصًا يتواجدون  مسؤول حقًا
وحذرًا عندما يتعلق الأمر بـ covid19 ، هناك أشخاص آخرون متعجرفون للغاية يتخلون عن حذرهم
وهذا يعرض الجميع للخطر